thanks Norman for that effusive
introduction it's really a great
pleasure to welcome Timothy Garton ash
who is a professor of European studies
at st. Anthony's college at Oxford a
senior fellow at the Hoover Institution
and author of seven books a member of
the european academy of arts and
sciences he's received the order of
merit from germany poland and the czech
republic and i have to say most
important from my perspective but i
don't really know the answer he has an
honorary degree from st. Andrews and the
question is do you get access to the old
course if you get an honorary degree if
so I'm actually truly truly envious know
you could have bargained for that
probably though and most importantly I
think in terms of his intellectual
history and record it's not only
exemplary in a kind of normal way but he
was one of the very very few people to
understand what was happening in eastern
and central europe in the 1980s and who
actually got it right and actually
foresaw and a very insightful what was
too info with the end of the Cold War
he's written a new book on European
American relations he's going to speak
today about a new beginning and what we
can hope is actually that your insight
and accuracy in the 80s is actually
replicated in terms of what you see is a
possibility for future relations and
cooperation between the US and Europe so
Timothy Garton now it's a pleasure to
have
well thank thank you very much for that
very kind introduction and it's a great
pleasure to be back here I've actually
just at the end of a two and a half week
tour which was mainly on the East Coast
and rather eccentric Lee I've flown
across to the west coast for about 12
hours before going back to Oxford which
may sound illogical but actually
Stanford is my home from home and really
has become so and so it does make sense
to come to the home from home before
going home and I'm very grateful to the
European form to the Institute normal
neymar in particular for arranging this
lecture and indeed of course to the
Hoover Institution for bringing me here
every year now my title is a new
beginning ? what the United States can
do with Europe now I would have to say
and this title was of course concocted
before Tuesday November the second and I
would have to say in all honesty that
the ? has I think got a bit larger since
Wednesday November preferred that is to
say it is self-evident and this is not
in any way a political statement but it
is a self-evident that it would have
been easier to talk about a new
beginning with the president kerry i
think that is self-evidently the case
but clearly we start from where we are
my subtitle what the United States can
do with your now I I sought a bit about
the UM preposition
one night I said what the United States
can do for Europe now or what the United
States can do to Europe now or about or
against but I decided to stick with with
but that in itself can be read two ways
you could say in the familiar phrase you
know what you can do with Europe and it
has to be said that I think there have
been some people in the can't Bush
administration who have used the word
rather in that spirit and in particular
and this is I think new have been of the
view that you can afford to ignore
Europe that Europe is of secondary if
not tarry importance to the interests of
the United States which I want to argue
as a mistake but i also want to use the
word within the much more positive sense
of what we can do together now I'm going
to proceed is roughly hi proceed in the
book that's to say in the first part of
my remarks I'm going to talk about I'm
going to make an analysis of this crisis
of the West do what I call history of
the present the crisis of the west which
became acute over the Iraq war but is
still I think withers and then in the
second part i'm going to try and be more
prescriptive as i do in the second part
of the book and answer comrade Lenin's
question what is to be done first the
analysis we talked about and the
analysis has to I think very much to
start with the world not just with
Europe in the United States we all talk
about the post-911 world I think the
world in which we live is defined by two
911s the first is the 11th of September
2001 the fall of the Twin Towers in New
York but the other is 911 written
European style with the day before the
month the 9th of November 1989 the fall
of the Berlin Wall the 911 of hope that
preceded the 911 of fear and cursed
enough i think that the deeper causes of
this crisis of the West actually have to
be traced back to the first 911 to the
fall of the berlin wall in the end of
the Cold War even the moment of triumph
are the seeds of the disaster and i
think the effects of the end of the Cold
War in Telegraph at brevity are too
firstly in very obviously europe in the
united states are no longer held
together by a single clear common enemy
in the center of Europe in Germany in
Berlin the Red Army the Soviet threat
and the Soviet threat was the was not
just the glue it was the cement of the
transatlantic relationship of the Cold
War West it whatever the difference is
in the Cold War it brought us back
together again every time a former
British Foreign Secretary recently
remarked to me Tim you know if only we
had Brezhnev back he sighed which is a
british point of view they're not i
think a polish won the second effect of
the end of the Cold War it seems to me
is that Europe finally lost its
centrality to world politics which it
had had arguably for at least 400 years
and which geopolitical centrality hadn't
away been artificially restored despite
the self destruction of Europe between
nineteen fourteen and nine t45 had been
artificially restored in the cold war by
the fact that the conflict of the
superpowers
with focused on Berlin and Germany in
Central Europe lost and gone no longer
the central theatre world politics and
indeed particularly viewed from
Washington Europe can look increasingly
marginal to the United States foreign
policy concerns so there's I think of
the two structural changes that underlie
the crisis of relations between Europe
in the United States and I think any
analysis of where we stand now has to
start by looking at the world where in a
completely transformed world now in
trying to describe that world my own
view is it the war on terror as a simple
shorthand for the world wherein is very
inadequate is one-dimensional and in
some respects misleading it's suggesting
as it does an analogy with the First
World War the Second World War even the
Cold War I do believe that one of the
major challenges of our time is the
combination of terrorism's I emphasize
the plural terrorism's weapons of mass
destruction some of which can be carried
in a suitcase and the existence of rogue
or failed States I believe that
combination is a new kind of threat
which defines the politics of our time
and as so often actually advances in
military technology produce a kind of
quantity and qualitative change in in
the politics but i think it's only one
of the great challenges that define our
time in the book I list a number of
great challenges a list is not
exhaustive I call them the new Red
Army's let me mention just for one is
the modernization liberalisation
eventual democratization of the whole
wider Middle East notably of the 22
members of the Arab League amongst whom
there is not a single not a single
democracy something which is a vital
interest to Europe which is just next
door secondly the rise or perhaps more
accurately the Renaissance of the Far
East after Japan India and in particular
China it seems to me that we are so used
to assuming that most of the most most
of the wealth and list of the power
resides in the West but we sometimes
forget that it was not always so and
will not always be so because after all
it has been saved for about 500 years
but the fact is of course if you go back
seven eight nine hundred years then
Huntington's alternative civilizations
particularly the Islamic and the Chinese
worlds were both in most respects more
advanced than European civilization and
now if we look at the trends the
extraordinary dynamism of the far
eastern economies particularly Indiana
above all China and we look ahead and I
know obviously that many things as many
a slip that many things can intervene to
slow down these trends but if we look at
the trends it seems probable that in 20
or 30 years time China in particular
will be a world power of such size and
and
strength that it will really transform
the geometry of world politics and that
is a challenge equally to Europe in the
United States thirdly and I'm really
just listing these challenges without we
could talk about the morn discussion the
divide between rich north and poor south
the truly shaming fact that a half of
humankind lives on less than two dollars
a day and that most of the next billion
who are likely to be born as well
population grows are going to be born
into poverty and not into riches and
finally the undoubted scientifically
established fact that the surface of the
earth is warming at an unprecedented
truly unprecedented rate and the very
high probability put it no stronger than
that the very high probability that
human agency particularly greenhouse gas
emissions are greenhouse gas emissions
if I may say so quickly your greenhouse
gas emissions the United States is the
SUV among nations are contributing to
global warming and we are already seeing
the effects in terms of a climate change
the summer of 2003 by the way the sum of
the Iraq crisis was the hottest summer
on record for 500 years now you could
add other challenges to that list we
could talk about aids we could override
Russia but my essential point here is
twofold firstly I would challenge anyone
in this room to show me how in any of
these areas the vital long-term
interests of Europe and the United
States differ in any significant way in
any significant way our interests are
either common or coincident or at the
very least
pata por and secondly I would challenge
anyone to show me how any of these great
challenges of our time can be
successfully addressed without the joint
and coordinated action of Europe and the
United States and I believe I could
demonstrate that compellingly in each of
the cases I have mentioned and perhaps
we can come back to that in the
discussion so those are my two key
points about looking at the world where
in that essentially coolly analyzed our
interests are clearly overwhelming it
common and that none of these great
challenges can be tackled without trying
to actual cooperation between you up in
the United States and as I say I hope we
can explore how in detail in in the
discussion yet very large numbers of
people on both sides of the Atlantic
clearly don't see it that way and we
have clearly a great divide in terms of
at least its claim attitudes approaches
what are called values we've had a lot
of talk about values in the United
States over the last two weeks many
claims are made about diverging European
and American values in the transatlantic
surveys you find that large majorities
of both Europeans and Americans believe
that the other have different values
Europeans believe that of Americans and
Americans believe that of Europeans this
view is of course famously summed up in
Robert Kagan's now famous or infamous
phrase Americans are from Mars Europeans
are from Venus
now one of the things I try to do like
one of the things I do in this book is
to demonstrate I believe conclusively
that it isn't so and I believe that is
an empirical statement not a state front
of prescription or wishful thinking it
is an empirical statement and I have a
lot of empirical evidence to show that
actually our systems both political and
economic our societies our attitudes our
values are much less different than we
believe in aggregate for example
everyone says oh Europe has these
overwhelming welfare states and the
caricature of the United States follows
as the sort of Darwinian capitalist
drummondville it's very interesting i
went back and looked at the proportions
of federal spending in the united states
since 1945 military spending as against
social spending poorly conceived
including healthcare medicare medicaid
education veterans and so on 1945 2%
social spending 89% military the other
percentages are of the other categories
at the end of Clinton Clinton second
term sixty-two percent social spending
sixteen percent military so complete
flip 289 262 16 and the projection is
that even after the huge hike in
military spending under this
administration the end of 2004 the
proportion will still be sixty-five
percent social spending to twenty
percent
military spending and as the baby
boomers as we know come up to retirement
so the burden of social spending the
burden of the health care system will
become overwhelming in other words we
had the same problem values these famous
values some of you will know the World
Values Survey which has been mapping
values for something like 30 years they
produce a very interesting map which I
we produce at the back of the book the
Englehart values map some of you may
know this which attempts to chart the
values on two axes we can talk about in
more detail but in discussion but the
basic point is what you do not get is
one clear coherent set of American
values and one clear coherent group of
European values what you get a clusters
of countries Catholic Europe Protestant
Europe post-communist Europe and the
english-speaking countries these are
Englehart four clusters Britain is of
course closer to the United States then
it is to Sweden let alone Romania but
actually froms in its values empirically
tested is closer to the United States
than it is to Sweden let alone Romania
so it simply is not the case that you
can define European identity versus
American identity on the on the basis of
measured values but as important looking
at this characterization of Americans
from Mars Europeans from Venus and many
aspects to this as important is the fact
that the truth is that what we face is
not one great divide down the middle of
the Atlantic Europe America
what we face is a story of two divided
continents the United States as we've
just seen in recent weeks but as in fact
many surveys have been picking up for
some time is quite deeply divided blue
America red America actually on many of
the issues of values of social justice
of priorities for government action and
attitudes to foreign policy
multilateralism versus unilateralism
divided on many issues that Europeans
regard as defining us that's to say but
another way if you disaggregate blue and
red America you find that on many of
these issues both domestic and foreign
blue America is actually much closer to
most Europeans then it is to read
America not on all I don't want to
simplify but on many issues blue America
closer to Europeans than to read America
which of course in census one of the
charges made against for example Bill
Clinton and for example let me give you
one recent example of that the German
Marshall Fund had a survey of
transatlantic trends transatlantic
survey one question was is military
force the best way to win the war on
terror more Americans answer yes and
Europeans but if you disagree gate blue
and red Democrats and Republicans then
what you find is less Democrats answered
yes than the French so the French were
more from Mars than the Democrats and is
it perhaps that actually it's
Republicans who are from Mars and
Democrats are from Venus I've been very
struck I actually have a website out of
this book free world web drop net in
which people can continue the debate
and I invite you to visit it it's a very
interesting debate and what's so
striking about it is that the fiercest
polemics a knot between Europeans and
Americans they're not between French and
Americans are not between French and
Brits there between Americans and
Americans this is where it gets really
sharp Europe too is divided divided in
many ways across many lines between
countries between classes between
generations but above all divided in one
great argument which is what i call the
argument between euro atlantis ism whose
most eloquent spokesman is tony blair
and which argues that we need a strong
united Europe but as a conscious partner
to the United States and what I call
euro goal ism who his most prominent
spokesman his reaction arc which argues
that we need a strong united Europe as a
rival super part of the United States
the polite term for that is of course
multipolarity and it was very
interesting to see immediately after
bush's reelection how both these two
positions were immediately articulated
by the two leaders of the camps blair
rushing off to Washington to reaffirm
the transatlantic partnership and
Jacques Chirac saying this and I quote
to give you a sample of heretics press
this was his immediate and really first
public reaction to the election I quote
it is clear that Europe now more than
ever has a need the necessity to
strengthen its dynamism and unity when
faced with this great world power I
let's build a rival superpower and the
point of our multipolarity is not
incidental because one of the most for
me worrying aspects of what Chirac has
been up to is um
the game he's been playing with China
which seems to me really quite shameless
and quite grotesque he has literally
painted the Eiffel Tower read that is to
say when the Chinese President came to
visit him in Paris if you remember the
Eiffel Tower was illuminated in red in
honor of the Chinese President he
subsequently been to Beijing made no
criticism of the human rights record of
the Chinese regime essentially endorsed
mainland China's position on Taiwan
without reservation and said that he
thinks the EU should lift its arms
embargo on arms exports to China without
essentially any conditions either
relating to human rights or to Taiwan
and in return he got a few trade
contracts and poked Washington in the
eye which were his two purposes now what
we see here is thus the advancing shadow
of a new great game of power politics in
the Triangle China Europe United States
and David Shambo is actually a great
expert on China has gone so far as to
talk about a China Europe axis that I
think is a bridge too far but
nonetheless the advancing shadow of a
game in which were put it this way in
the 1970s Henry Kissinger played the
China card against the Soviet Union
today China is playing the Europe card
against the United States and Chirac and
others of enabling him to do that so I
think that is a very alarming
constellation now let me turn and I'm
coming to the close of my first part of
my analysis of the history of the
present let me turn to the present on
the new beginning with the question mark
I wrote an op-ed before the election in
which I argued that it seemed to me
probable unfortunately that the
reelection of President
Bush would considerably strengthened the
Euro goalies tendency in Europe at the
tendency I have described and I'm afraid
to say that despite some very
significant gestures that have been made
by the administration um and we'll come
back to that in a moment I see that
happening already I believe the bush
reelection has put wind into the sales
of the euro go least tendency in europe
and i would go so far as to say and this
can only be a hunch that jacques chirac
for example was not altogether unhappy
at bush's reelection because i say in
some sense it strengthens his position
and i am afraid to say that i believe
that despite the gestures of goodwill
that are being made at the moment if one
looks at the really difficult set of
issues that are on the agenda between
europe in the United States from Iraq
through the very difficult issue of Iran
and how to stop that regime developing
nuclear weapons to relations with China
and this difficult question of the arms
embargo I mean there are plenty of
possible crises and I wonder very much
whether the new beginning will in fact
long survive another crisis between us
and I fear that um the the reaction in
Washington to a year ago lyst gambit on
one of these issues would be to do what
the Bush administration has done in its
first term which is to say actually we
don't want to work we don't want them to
need to work with the European Union as
such as our preferred partner why bother
we will pick and choose we will cherry
pick we will choose our individual
partners among the powers of Europe the
Brits have a loyal or is rely on them
the poles the Italian so long as you
have bellus Coney and great Ally thought
we had the Spaniards but mysteriously
Spain some house which can be new Europe
to Old Europe overnight as it was out of
an election but nonetheless a sufficient
Coalition of the Willing can be found in
other words what Richard hearts a
moderate Republican former head of
policy planning in the State Department
called disaggregation or what the
ancient Romans called DVD empire divide
and rule in Europe and this in turn if
the administration did revert to that
practice whether one how a man wishes
describe it cherry picking coalition's
of the Willing divide and rule that
would of course greatly aggravate and
offend large parts of European opinion
and would therefore further strengthen
the Euro goalies tendency so I fear and
this is the end of my analysis that we
face not just a possibility but I would
argue I fear the probability of a
further downward spiral in the
transatlantic relationship in the manner
I've described that's the end of the
analysis that's as far as I think there
were the history of the present let me
turn now to an attempt at prescription
to the question what is to be done even
in this quite difficult situation it
seems to me that if
the new Bush administration wants to
change the dynamics of the relationship
I'm led by Stanford zone Hoover's own
dr. condoleezza rice as a new secretary
of state and to work against the trends
i describe their two key things that
need to happen at least two key things
to suggestions that I would make one is
that given these very deep suspicions in
Europe about American policies of divide
and rule the administration would start
with a very clear and emphatic statement
perhaps a presidential trip to Brussels
and a clear and emphatic statement that
the you that the United States wants to
work with the European Union as a whole
and the United States considers as it
has done from most of the paid since
1945 that European integration and its
success is in the American national
interest I think that message would be
enormously helpful in Europe now one
thing I recount in the book is a very
interesting meeting that I and a couple
of others had with President Bush in May
2001 but before nine before his first
trip to the to Europe and I got a
telephone call in my office in Oxford
one afternoon and a voice said them this
is the White House here could you come
and tell the president about Europe 145
on Thursday
so I said well I do have a lunch but
i'll i'll try and change it and then
they flew me over i have to say coach
class and we had a fascinating i'm more
of a turn on and we had a truly
fascinating conversation and one thing
of many that i will never forget was a
moment when the president you know new
and office new to the fron affairs
broadly speaking looked us in the eye
and said do we want the european union
to succeed and when my british colleague
and I and in fact interesting off the
only two europeans present were Brits no
French air Germans no poles when my
greatest colleague and I said very
emphatically that we certainly wanted
the European Union to succeed and we
hope that the United States would to the
president said oh that was only a
provocation only provocation well some
provocation it seems to me that it's
hard to imagine that any earlier
American president between 1945 and 2001
would have asked the question in that
frontal form do we want the European
Union to succeed that is to say the
premise of American policy would have
been that in principle we do want the
European Union to succeed we have some
problems with particular aspects of it
and that i think was reflected in the
subsequent policy of the bush
administration so that this very
emphatic strategic statement visible for
all to see we want the european union if
succeed we want the whole of the
european union as our transatlantic
partner would be of great importance
incidentally it has a tactical advantage
that you don't have to kiss and make up
with Jacques Chirac or gerhard schröder
because you don't have to get a parasol
berlin you go to Brussels and you
embrace the President of the European
Commission mr. Barroso and Xavier Solana
both of whom are Iberian euro Atlantis
they're good partners and then you
embrace the assembled heads of Satan
government of the European Union and
NATO the second thing I would do if
anyone were listening to me would be
immediately and quite decisively to
broaden the agenda seems to me if you're
the United States and you want help in
Iraq and the Europeans to get tough on
Iran the one thing you shouldn't do is
just ask Europeans for help in Iraq and
to get tough on Iran because you had the
answer no broaden the agenda to the
whole palette of issues on which we do
have these compelling strategic common
interests in the enlargement of freedom
and by all means speak the language of
the enlargement of freedom Iraq Israel
Palestine Iran Afghanistan Darfur the
thematic issues that I've mentioned the
wider Middle East managing the emergence
of China as a world power the Doha round
climate change two reasons for
broadening the agenda one tactical the
other strategic the tactical reason was
rather nicely expressed by some you will
know the British scholar diplomat robert
cooper who actually roped the European
security strategy which is quite an
interesting answer to the American
national security strategy and Robert
quoted the other day a remark of janmani
janmani is he said if you have a problem
you can't solve enlarge the context and
I thought this was a wonderful remarks i
emailed Robert and I said Robert could
you answer fantastic i want to quote it
could you um tell me where Jean Monnet
said it and Robert email back in Ireland
turbaned ass but someone told me that
someone told him that Jean Monnet said
it but said Robert and I love this I'm
morally certain
that money said it more or less a dancer
whether it was money or rob cooper or as
someone told me the other day actually
james madison in the Federalist Papers
it's a great piece of diplomatic advice
enlarge the context but the other reason
for doing it is it is simply
substantively correct this is the truth
strategic agenda as I tried to lay out
at the beginning for Europe in the
United States and we should face it
squarely now before throwing is open for
questions and comments and discussion I
want to say one last thing in conclusion
which is is I've been talking a lot
about challenges dangers threats and it
seems to me the whole language in which
we talk about world politics since nine
eleven has been a language of dangers
and threats and fears in a sense between
the first 911 and a second 911 we had a
language of hope and opportunity now we
have a language of dangers and fears and
many of those dangers are real but I
think it's important to realize that
beyond that we do actually live in a
time of great opportunity and the
subtitle of the British edition of this
book is why a crisis of the west reveals
the opportunity of our time Random House
said that was too complicated for
America and said the American subtitle
is America comma Europe and the
surprising future of the West but
simpler the Canadians by the way took
the American edition identical in every
respect but they change the subtitle
back for Canada and why a crisis of the
west reveals the opportunity of the time
because I argue that like an electric
storm it does indeed reveal the common
interests that we do in fact
and it reveals the opportunity and the
opportunity is this in 1974 before the
revolution of the carnations in Portugal
freedom has counted 39 democracies in
the world this year Freedom House cancer
a hundred and seventeen democracies in
the world out of 192 sovereign states
the truly dramatic and unprecedented
increase we could argue about Vitaly I
make it 160 because they can't Russia
and it seems to me extremely difficult
to argue that Russia today is in any
meaningful sense of democracy I think
actually the more compelling figure is
not that tally of one hundred and
sixteen or seventeen democracies which
includes electoral democracies and not
in any way less liberal democracies but
their figure of 88 free countries which
i think is quite well-documented 88 free
countries in which some 2.8 billion
people live let's say nearly half of
humankind lives in free countries there
has never been a time in human history
this is I think a simple factual
statement where more people have been
more free and where indeed we have more
possibilities of the further enlargement
of freedom we don't face great
totalitarian blocks nuclear-armed
totalitarian blocks in the way that we
did throughout the Cold War and I think
we should take heart and courage from
that from understanding that opportunity
this lecture was set to mark two
occasions one is in a sense the election
of the 44th President of the United
States the other is the 15th anniversary
of the fall of the Berlin Wall the 9th
of November
this year now I just want to take you
back for a moment in conclusion to what
it felt like a few years before the fall
of the Berlin war and take you into the
kitchen of a tiny apartment in a
battered office block in Warsaw and a
couple of dissident friends of mine
their friends were in prison Brezhnev
was in the Kremlin they lived in a
communist police state censorship
repression and there they were rolling
out on the kitchen table with a squeegee
a squeegee ink press the first number of
a sum as that journal 1978 and they
wrote in the first editorial of the
first number our objective is an
independent democratic free Poland 1978
that seemed like aiming or bicycle at
the planet Mars 12 years later it came
true the walls came down the impossible
happened and it seems to me if they were
capable of that vision and that courage
and that politics of hope politics is
the art of the impossible we might have
a little more vision and courage and
refuse what I call the illusions of
impotence the illusions of impotence
because what we face above all now in
our politics particularly new up in the
United States is not any more concrete
walls but what I call the mind walls the
walls in our head the walls of prejudice
and ignorance and selfishness and the
opportunity we face is nothing less it's
not just to be clear that it is not to
reconstruct the old Cold War west of
Europe in the United States that's
finished that's down for it won't come
back again
it is to move forward from the Old West
to what I call a post West a wider
community of democracies including
countries like India and Taiwan Latin
American democracies which was not
belonged historically and culturally to
what in American universities used to be
called once upon a time western civ a
post west a much wider and widening
Community of Democracies in other words
and this is a central argument of my
book on with this I end the opportunity
we face is to move from the free world
of the Cold War and now anachronistic
and in some sense i think compromised
term if you remember Jeanne Kirkpatrick
considered at one point that pinochet's
chile belonged to the free world ie the
anti-communist West the opportunity we
face is to move forward from ver free
world which will never come back again
towards a free world to adapt Winston
Churchill never in the history of
grandma has a shift from the definite to
the indefinite article be more important
thank you
okay we have time for questions and
comments I asked you to keep them brief
and straight and we have microphones
here so that you can be heard you would
ask you just to come to the microphones
you have any questions
hi my name is Vanessa I'm really
Institute I'm from Europe and one thing
that I've missed in your in your talk is
the role of public opinions in Europe
you describe them actually in your in
your book particularly in the run-up to
the war in Iraq and how these public
opinions have basically taken on a
majority part different position than
that of their governments including
encounters like Britain and Italy and
Spain under the snar and so so when you
when you go out around Europe and talk
about this issue what do you tell what
you tell them as opposed to what you
tell to you know politicians and and and
academicians who see things apparently
differently and then a second quick
question because you mentioned
Condoleezza Rice do you expect that with
her at the State Department things may
change in a direction or another thank
you um thank you yeah um I mean I tell
readers in Europe exactly what I told
you and it's quite interesting sexually
this book is already come out in German
and it's coming out in italian spanish
portuguese italian spanish french or
polish all the major european languages
in the next few months and each
discussion is very very interesting the
debate is very interesting but the
position on public opinion is a bit more
complicated that's to say the
overwhelming majority of European public
opinion was against the war on Iraq as
conducted by the Bush administration
with a few European allies starting in
march 2003 that is absolutely true right
but if you look at the surveys by the
pew research center and the German
Marshall Fund on others the picture is
more complicated European public
opinions are well able to distinguish
between their attitudes to the bush
administration and their attitudes to
America so that it is not the case that
there is a majority for euro go lyst
position to core yeah there was a
majority against the Iraq war but not
for the Euro goal is position in fact if
look more closely you will find that I
believe there is a silent majority for
the euro Atlantis's position although
that remains to be tested and I would
very much welcome it if from this
administration and the State Department
under under complete arise were two
tests our proposition I mean as you will
see I think the United States should
take the gamble it is a gamble but you
can win the whole of the European Union
to be your partner in this great
endeavor rather than just settling for a
few individual European states there's I
mean there have been quite a few
significant gestures that the president
said in his first press conference that
you know in in effect he wanted via pin
union exceed wanted to work with the
European Union they've now announced
that there will be a trip in meet soon
after the inauguration to Brussels you
know there is a certain breakthrough on
Iran sudden division of labor between as
it were the American hard [ __ ] and
European soft cop we shall see how it
goes i think there was a real
opportunity there and i am sure that
condi rice understands that opportunity
but as I say the test will come in the
first crisis and I suspect that crisis
will come sooner rather than later
I think my crew yeah could be Iran and
there's actually a hopeful development
which are keenly aware of which is the
three European contact powers who've
been dealing with Iran seem to have made
a breakthrough agreement in persuading
the Iranians to cease the enrichment of
uranium and suspend what I think most
observers think is a covert nuclear
program and if this holds I really think
it may wind up averting what could have
been a real catastrophe both globally
and for euro-american relations all over
again which would have been a preemptive
strike probably using Israel as a proxy
against the Iranian nuclear facilities
and this you know I'd love your reaction
to this is this kind of a glimmer of
hope of what can we expect and more
generally you know what does this say
about the initiatives that Europe might
take acting as a union that might draw
the Bush administration in to take this
gamble because I think you phrased it
exactly the right way what else might be
done on specifically on that first
opportunity you mentioned of
democratization and the broader Middle
East on the Middle East peace process
and on some of these other initiatives
that would I guess there's one way to
put it is to appeal to the better angels
within the Bush administration Thank You
Larry I'm a good question I mean on Iran
I would have said a week or two ago that
Iran was likely to be the next or our
crisis it's getting likely to be the
next crisis of the west and sooner
rather than later this is a glimmer of
hope but glimmer is exactly right and
it's an interesting case because it
shows you that
what is needed is not always the classic
division of labor in which Europe is a
soft crop and the u.s. is a hard [ __ ]
Europe often scallops and the US off of
sticks because actually what's needed in
this case is it Europe we waves a bigger
stick and the United States waves a
bigger carrot I mean that seems to me
the way forward is that we have a bigger
joint stick in other words European
countries are prepared to take it to the
UN are prepared in the end to impose
sanctions but also that the United
States is prepared to take the risk and
offer the carrot or full normalization
so that's where we should go whether
both sides are ready to go that place
I'm I wouldn't bet on it and second
breakthrough is of course Israel
Palestine that needs to be mentioned and
again and it would be a foolish person
who bet much money on achieving these
settlement between if L and the
Palestinians but nonetheless there is
another glimmer of hope a moment of
opportunity and that is of course it has
to mentioned an issue which has enormous
potential for producing bad blood
between Europe and the United States
enormous potential because Palestine I
witnessed the huge anti-bush
demonstration in London when he went to
visit Tony Blair and trafalgar square
and vast with them incidentally a mullah
crying alaska bar from the bottom of
Nelson's column I'm a memorable moment
what Nelson would have made it I didn't
know but the biggest banner at that
demonstration was a huge huge banner
which said free Palestine right and on
the other hand obviously particularly
interest in Israel from the United
States and if things go wrong then it
very very rapidly descends in
to those accusations that we have seen
already over the last few years
accusations of European anti-semitism as
the main motive for backing the
Palestinians which i think is incorrect
and accusations of you know whether word
Zionist conspiracy among the neo-cons
and so on says it's potentially a very
damaging issue what the European Union
should do it is very clear to me now we
should say this president is a very odd
kind of conservative he's not a kind of
conservative that we know in Europe he
is on the one hand jacksonian yeah
something we don't really have in here
but he's on the other hand wilsonian
this is a man who rarely talks
passionately about the spread of
democracy the promotion of freedom yeah
and his press conference with Tony Blair
with an absolutely extraordinary because
he ended up saying I really believe in
democracy because I believe that
democracies don't fight each other
Immanuel Kant george w bush's become
Immanuel Kant it's the opposite of what
Robin Kagan said do you know Europeans
of the Canton's and the Americans are
hugs in now it's the other way around
but you know there is a genuine
wilsonian and indeed can t an element
that and our response should be to say
we absolutely agree with you about the
end this is the most important thing we
need to do and this is what we can
contribute you can't do it on your own
you can't do it just with military force
we Europeans have decades of experience
and democracy promotion in Central and
Eastern Europe we know how to support
opposition groups we know how to do
independent media we know how to support
civil society we know how to use trade
and credit as linkages we know how to
open our markets as an incentive we know
how to bring young people from the Arab
world to our universities we know how to
encourage millions of people to come as
tourists that's opening their eyes to
the experience of the West
this is complicated yeah it can't be
summarized in one sentence but let's put
it on the table and I think that is
exactly what Europe should do next
degree yes I would like I to hear your
view on the effect of radical Islamists
in Holland France London Germany
Brussels Antwerp etc I'm it's a good
question I'm couple of points first of
all I think the degree to which French
policy was dictated by the motive of
appeasing the Muslim population in
France is overstated I've no doubt it
was a subcutaneous element but you know
there are plenty of other French reasons
for behaving as France did without that
and to go behave like that in many ways
when at a time when there weren't
millions of Muslim immigrants in France
I think that particular factor has ever
sated secondly it is much easier for an
extremist mullah to get a preaching job
in London or Paris than it is for them
to get a teaching job in Istanbul or
Ankara I mean it's a curious fact about
our free societies that that we make it
easy for extremist preachers come to our
that societies um thirdly I think it is
one of how we make Muslim immigrants
feel at home in Europe is one of the
biggest challenges the biggest
challenges in front of Europe the fact
is that the politics of immigration have
already nearly destabilized the party
systems a Western Europe lepen
pim fortuyn haider the list goes on now
in even the UK Independence Party the
politics of immigration of nearly
destabilized old established party
systems with relatively low levels of
immigration certainly compared to the
United States because of our aging
population because of the pressures from
meniere's were going to get a hell of a
lot more immigration so how we hope with
that how we don't build up these
extraordinary alienated populations in
the Bunya of Paris and the outskirts of
Madrid who are in fact which are in fact
the breeding grounds of the terrorists
right it is no accident that some of the
people who flew into the World Trade
Center became radical Islamists in
Hamburg and of course the Bombers in
Madrid Moroccans living in Madrid and
there's a particular difficulty I mean I
as you will see I don't have an easy
answer but there is a particular
difficulty which is in a Turk sometimes
say you're not taking us in because
you're a Christian Club misunderstanding
if Europe at some point says no to
Turkey it won't be because we're
Christian Club this book is where
secular club because the religion of
Europe is secularism our belief is
non-belief that's what unites us and it
seems to me it is the case that it's
actually more difficult in a sense for
religious Muslims to feel at home in a
set highly secular society in a curious
way than it is for them to feel at home
in a more religious society like that of
the United States yeah I think a
believing Muslim can feel more alienated
in Hamburg or London than in Kansas
curiously enough because as a religious
person you are surrounded by other
religious people many of whom believe in
the same God so I think it is a hue
huge challenge for Europe one of the
biggest to make Muslim immigrants feel
at home good evening yakushiji I'm a
student in the history department I have
two related questions for you my first
deals with the challenges that you posed
early on to us to point out if we could
indicate anything that wouldn't indicate
a conflict of interest between Europe
and the United States and these were
long term criteria and I think the
solutions that you posed bear that out
in the sense of shifting toward the
European Union away from bilateral
relations and then broaden in the
context I want to press the question of
agency somewhat here basically all of
your your suggestions have revolved
around common cooperation between both
Europeans and Americans Graham curious
where you foresee the shift from the
short-term point of view that clearly
dominates now to a longer-term point of
view coming who is going to initiate the
shift obviously this is a little bit of
futurology but where does this actually
start happening and the second question
deals with the current nature of foreign
policy with respect to the EU even with
the new constitutional treaty bilateral
relations still seem to be very much
dominant in terms of foreign or
international dealings with the European
Union member states looking even at
let's say the Czech Republic or Poland
in general the post-communist States
especially are strong on the bilateral
relations even crush Nueske's comments
after Bush's elections you may bear that
out I'm curious if you see the maybe the
post-communist countries as being the
first step toward shifting away from
bilateralism toward community operations
and if not then how do we expect the
United States to treat the EU as a whole
if the hole is really just an ad-hoc
entity thank you
yeah very good questions briefly the
difference between a statesman or woman
and politician is precisely the
difference in someone who thinks about
the long-term and someone who only
thinks about the short-term one of our
problems in Europe at all in all
together in the last five years is that
we've had politicians rather than saves
when also hates women and I think Tony
Blair in some sense is the exception who
proves the rule as to say his someone
who does have a long-term strategy i
think the right long-term strategy but
his tactical maneuvering has actually
subvert it his own strategy right so we
need better leaders it's always easier
to say but I could do um now very also
very justified question about the EU I
mean the fact is the degree to which the
EU gets at least co-ordinated positions
is often underrated over here um you
know eighty percent of issues there are
co-ordinated EU position but they're the
easy ones of course or the important
ones like climate change hotel is a
common position or the Doha round
they're not the really difficult one the
Constitution provides for more coherent
wrong policymaking mechanism but whether
the Constitution will go through is
another question nonetheless you know
there is some movement in that direction
now I would say two things one is the
United States has always been a major
influence on the process of European
integration so actually you can
influence this process right if if the
United States keep saying not just
repeating the old Henry Kissinger whip
you say Europe which number should i
call which by the way I don't mean
Kissinger ever said like many of these
famous is like John money as many of
those most famous quotations in history
but I think he likes to think that he
did and but um if the United States says
please give us
we can call our default position is
always that we want to call Solana right
that's our default position on any issue
first choice work with European Union
come up with your common position and
we'll go with that understand that if
you can't come up with a common position
then we'll have to work with a smaller
group of states and in a lot of cases
like Iran you will end up with smaller
groups contact groups that seems to me
just fine so it's a true to track
strategy for the United States which
would be very helpful see I want to ask
you a question about France and ask it
in the most forceful way your premise is
that if we look at these major issues
there are no differences between europe
and the united states but i would say if
you look at the middle east and you look
at develop third world development you
can spin out a story about why France
would have a position antagonistic to
the United States and even the rest of
Europe if you want to play a role as a
major power France is more able to play
that role if the Middle East is divided
if the palestinian-israeli situation is
not settled and if you look at france's
role in francophone Africa for instance
that role is more prominent if those
countries are still linked to France not
particularly developing and still mired
in a kind of quasi colonial relationship
and the question is if you look at the
French a leech which is in my view
unique in the Western world in which you
have a relatively small cadre of people
who went to the same school running the
country their personal interests really
would deteriorate if these problems were
solved especially the third world in the
Middle East problem compared to their
position of the problems continue to be
exacerbated so the question is if we
look at France in particular is it
really the case that the United States
france share the same purposes or even
France and the rest of Europe it's it's
it's an excellent question um which goes
to the the definition of interests
doesn't it and if we say that the French
national interest is to be seen got a
dramatic figure on the world stage and
that he says it were the lasting
national interest of France and the
first national interest of France then
you might well be right that would seem
to me well as serious misunderstanding
of the French national interest now I
actually think that there is a there's a
French problem and there's a specific
chirac problem this man is extraordinary
and the head of another European State
said to me um he said when I first met
jacques chirac he thought he was the
Gold's grandson now he thinks he's digos
father
and it is absolutely extraordinary
hubris is his second name and I think
he's truly and something about sitting
in the alizee for too long I mean it
happens to all our leaders soon or later
but in the elisa house more than most he
truly seems we had lost touch with the
reality of French France is well
understood national interest yes so the
question then is is the rest of the
French Foreign Policy elite in the same
place and I think the answer is no I
really think the answer is now I have a
lot of intensive contacts with these
famous a narc people like jalan raya me
for example major foreign policy think
that they see it they see that French
policies on a hiding to know where that
actually the notion that you can
actually unite Europe around the policy
of being a superpower rival to the
United States is absolutely for the
birds because Europe will always produce
its own divisions and Washington the
only hyperpower will always be able to
exploit those divisions you cannot unite
Europe against the United States so it's
a hiding to know where maybe a few
particular interests in Africa in the
phone call phony better by the way i'm
told that even in the cote divoire this
is phase out to find boiled france even
in the cote divoire france is now very
unpopular and a journalist who was there
told me that him there in that country
there was a great demonstration with
people holding up banners saying please
America come and save us even in the
cote divoire so you know this is a
country which has a major problem
because it's on the losing side of
history they have I think a very
impressive elite which has in part grasp
that and doing things like teach could
see also in English working in business
in English working in the European
Union in English adapting in rather
remarkable ways Nicolas Sarkozy the
possible successor to share are not an a
knock by the way not from the classic a
lead is very interesting on this score a
realist a pragmatist he's made some
quite remark is strikingly critical
remarks about she rocks foreign policy
and the belief that you can call the
shots in Europe simply with Germany as
your only a partner so you know I agree
with you there plenty of grounds for
skepticism but i also think there are
significant figures in the French
political elite who are capable of
ultimately realism
one of Nixon's henchmen said don't
listen to what we say watch what we do
and I submit this is true of the first
Bush administration and my question is
to give credibility to whatever Bush may
say in Brussels what can and should the
United States do or not do thank you um
I am I think some extent I tried to
address that in the talk um I think you
go down that strategic agenda and you
say this is what we're going to do on
climate change no one expects the United
States to sign Kyoto the Congress won't
allow it but the plenty of things you
can actually do to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions without silent Kyoto this is
what we're going to do in the Doha round
this is where we you know in the first
year of an administration where we can
actually risk doing something unpopular
this is where we are gonna cotta
agricultural subsidies cotton subsidies
and song this is where we are going to
lower tariffs what ru de you going to do
this is how we're going to take the
israel-palestine peace process forward
those will be three very big things very
big things very important to Europeans
where you would be bringing something to
the table that Europeans actually want
and then you can sign it and now what we
need is a following kind of help in Iraq
as we're in earnest and what we need is
what we were just talking about in
relation to Iran that you actually
sacrifice some of your short-term
commercial interests in order to produce
the big stick in relations to Iran and
so on I think that's how the
conversation should go
yes I'm just a comment in connection
with what to do when you're faced with a
problem you don't know how to solve the
famous Stanford mathematician George
polio and is book how to solve it said
when you can't solve a problem there
must be an easier problem that you can't
solve either and you should first look
at that and then you'll learn how to
solve the harder one thank you first of
all I want to thank you very much for
very lucid and and I opening
presentation and I want to ask to
question the first relates to the
analytical part of you talk and the
second to the prescriptive with regards
to be analytical I mean it seems that
increasingly European foreign policy is
defined both by the internal integration
process that is happening in Europe we
see sort of enlargement as foreign
policy and we see really the emergence
of the EU defining itself as a community
of identity of a distinct identity
community or values my question I mean
this is associated with the notion of
soft power as chris patten recently put
it sort of soft power with a with a hard
edge with the development of cfsp etc do
you see that as a path dependence and as
a structured direction of European
foreign policy which is perhaps leading
away from American foreign policy you
haven't addressed that that aspect in
your presentation with regards to the
prescriptive do you think that a
concrete problem that the United States
may invite Europe to cooperate with it
on could at this moment be useful we
have another you know four more years of
bush probably another four or five more
years of Blair there's the issue of Gaza
which is an issue of State Building and
nation-building if I've ever seen one
and as you say Europe has
enormous experience in capital which it
has gained over the last 15 years in
central eastern europe in
democratization in institution building
could you see the American
administration turning to the European
Union and saying let's do this together
offer Israel closer political
integration in exchange for withdrawal
from Gaza and the West Bank offer Israel
a stake in the single market of the
European Union in exchange offer a
membership in the OSCE offer membership
and the Council of Europe helped the
Palestinian build the kind of
institutions which the quartet we forget
about this but you know a common us-eu
coordination mechanism has a fairly
coherent view about what needs to be
done do you think that that would be
helpful at this point thank you for for
both parts and the latter is a very
interesting suggestion um let me answer
you in in this general way that I'm they
struck by how outside this room it seems
to me most Americans don't get the
European Union they just don't get it
it's the mysterious and confusing and
obscure and and one reason i think is it
um is that you have to think about power
in a different way one of the problems
that seems to me with neoconservative
the Robert Kagan description of the
relations in Europe in America the
heading which was if you remember power
and weakness american power european
weakness is it it is predicated on
premise don a one-dimensional definition
of power let's say military power hard
hard power and in that measuring america
is all-powerful and europe is weak
economic power the European Union is in
many respects the equal of the United
States this is not soft power it's a
category mistake to say that economic
power of soft power the European Union
next year and China will be each other's
largest trading partner in front of the
United States the European Union blocked
the merger of two great American
companies General Electric and Honeywell
that's power economic power then we do
have soft power the power to attract so
much so that virtually all our neighbors
want to join the European Union and the
European Union has a peculiar kind of
power what I call the power of induction
which says to all our neighbors if you
do this that and the other if you make a
market economy if you respect certain
standards of human rights and minority
rights and the rule of law and so on
then somewhere down the road you can
draw in the club with enormous benefits
and this is a power that the United
States does not have and will not have
as far as I know Mexico and Canada are
not applying for membership of the
United States anytime soon and wouldn't
be offered it and so Europe is the
opinion is getting bigger in the United
States is not and that is one of the key
contributions that we can make to this
common transatlantic strategic agenda I
would argue that saying yes to opening
negotiations for EU membership for
Turkey in mid-december is at least as
large a contribution to fighting and
winning the war on terror as anything
we've done in Iraq if not larger to show
that an Islamist government with a prime
minister who five years ago we're saying
our minarets are our bayonets yeah it is
now working in the context of a secular
state and doing everything you can to
get into your opinion that's a huge
contribution okay suggestion on Israel
very interesting promise of membership
would be extremely difficult at this
part hard to imagine but they're things
you can do short of membership to
encourage that association so yes I take
that very much on board and i hope that
americans will in time understand this
different kind of power which is you
know not a cadillac it's more like a
herbaceous border it grows very slowly a
number of different plants and yet it
grows and testing conclusion um I know
Norman of course has worked a lot on
that great term farm policy strategist
Joseph Stalin and you will remember that
Joseph Stalin once said how many
divisions has the Pope well the Pope one
in the end and so if one asks how many
divisions has the European Union I'm i
like to think again thank you